cuando vemos la función escalón unitario
yo les comenté que este tipo de
funciones son un poquito más exóticas de
lo que normalmente están acostumbrados a
ver en alguna clase tradicional de
cálculo o en sus clases de álgebra pero
quise presentarles esta función porque
muchas cosas del mundo real se comportan
de esta manera en la que no pasa nada
durante cierto tiempo y de pronto para
sumen y cambian de valor aunque no
ocurren exactamente así pero la función
escalón unitario es una muy buena
aproximación a este comportamiento por
otra parte tenemos cosas que bueno de
repente no está pasando nada no pasa
nada durante cierto tiempo y de repente
fueron tenemos algo muy alto luego
vuelve a bajar y continúa sin pasar nada
ustedes pueden ver que esto se comporta
como un impulso y ya hablaremos de las
funciones impulso unitario y no sería
genial que tuviéramos un tipo de función
que nos permitirá modelar este
comportamiento
nuestra función ideal sería una que va
sin tener un cambio no pasa nada hasta
que llegando a cierto valor
sube con la fuerza infinita pero que
tiene un área finita y después
regresaría a su valor normal continuaría
así así que digamos que llegando aquí a
un cero sube baja en ese mismo instante
también y continúa con el mismo valor y
digamos que el área bajo esta curva
aunque llamara a esto una función sería
llegar a los límites de las matemáticas
que estamos trabajando en este nivel
pero ustedes no pueden decir bueno y
esto para qué me sirve es bueno
permítanme hacer una definición más
acerca de esta función de hecho a esta
función la voy a llamar delta delta de x
y es llamada la función delta de dirac y
esto digamos que informalmente vamos a
decir que esto es igual a infinito
cuando x es igual a 0 y es igual a 0 en
cualquier otro valor cuando x es
diferente de 0 bueno cómo voy a hacer la
integral de esto bueno esto viene dentro
de la definición como parte de la
definición se les va a decir cuál es la
integral esta integral va a ser parte de
esta definición de la función y aquí se
las voy a decir la integral de esta
función de menos infinito hasta infinito
en toda esta línea numérica
yo estoy definiendo que la integral de
esta función delta de irak de x va a ser
igual a 1 yo lo estoy especificando así
ustedes podrían decirme oye pues es que
no me lo has demostrado no al contrario
lo estoy especificando yo lo estoy
definiendo así que tiene una base
infinitamente pequeña y una altura
infinitamente grande y el área que yo
les estoy definiendo aquí abajo que es
algo una función medio loca incluso
ustedes me pueden preguntar oye pues es
que yo quiero comprender mejor cómo es
que alguien puede construir este tipo de
funciones y de hecho lo vamos a ver y
una vez que hayamos satisfecho esta
curiosidad vamos a ver cómo es la
transformada de laplace de esta función
e incluso cómo manipularla para que nos
sea útil completamos esta delta de acá y
vamos a construir una nueva función que
voy a llamar de subíndice está o
y eso es sólo para satisfacer la
curiosidad que ustedes tengan para
comprender mejor cómo construir estas
funciones delta direct digamos que mi
función de subíndice está o está en
función de t y lo hago así porque quiero
que todo esté en términos para poder
aplicarse la transformada de la clase
que trabaja en el dominio de t así que
digamos que esto es igual
1 / 2 town y ya verán por qué estoy
eligiendo estos números 1 / 2 está o
cuando te es menor qué tal
es mayor que menos estado y va a tener
el valor de 0 en todos los demás valores
en todos los demás valores
esa es una ecuación un poquito más
razonable porque parece una combinación
de la función de escalón unitario la
cual ya hemos visto en vídeos anteriores
si yo comienza a dibujar mi eje de las x
aquí en verde mi eje de las x
voy a dibujar mi eje de las 10 aquí y
esto es x no mejor no aquí le ponemos el
eje de las tres y aquí podemos poner nos
sale una efe dt no importa esta es una
variable dependiente de t que va a pasar
aquí
bueno puede tener cero hasta que llegó a
menos usted
entonces aquí llego a menos
y esta es más está
de menos a más esta va a ser cero en
cualquier otro lugar
cuando llegó el valor de menos estado va
a saltar y va a tener un valor aquí
hasta que se llega a bastado y después
de ese nivel va a bajar ese nivel es uno
entre dos estados
aquí lo pongo en el eje de pendiente 1 /
como voy a construir esta función
bueno vamos a pensar en ello
qué pasa si yo hago la integral bueno
déjenme dibujar una integral más bonita
la integral de menos infinito hasta
infinito
de subíndice estado de t de t
aquí va a ser igual a esto
bueno recordemos que la integral es el
área bajo una curva
por lo que esta curva sería algo muy
fácil de calcular vemos que va a tener
un valor de 0 en cualquier otro lugar
y el área que me interesa es la de aquí
que la que está abajo de esta curva por
lo que va a ser la integral de menos t o
menos tao tao ya que no tiene casos en
la integral en otros valores porque pues
va a ser cero el área va a ser cero de
uno entre dos portado de tal verdad
dt así que podemos escribir de esta
forma también
ya que movemos nuestros límites de aquí
a acá porque no tiene caso ser la
integral de algo que vale 0 sin importar
si te es mayor que tal o te es menor que
menos está y dentro de ese límite esta
función es una constante uno entre dos
estados así que podemos tomar esta
integral y como la evaluamos ni siquiera
tenemos que saber cálculo para hacerlo
este es el área bajo esta curva que es
simplemente la base esto es igual la
base la base es 22 está aquí hay un tau
y aquí ya total igualado estado
multiplicado por la altura y la altura
ya lo definimos es igual a uno entre dos
estados
hacemos esta operación
el área de esta función nos va a quedar
igual a 1 o si quieren podemos resolver
la anti derivada la anti derivada de uno
entre dos estados va a ser igual vamos a
cambiarlo de color va a ser igual a t
entre 2 está o cuando esté evaluado de
menos estado a estado
todo entre tostado menos
- está entre los estados así que hacemos
esta operación estaba un estado es igual
adoptado entre dos estados es igual a 1
llegamos al mismo resultado
y yo creo que con esto ustedes ya
estarán convencidos de que el área bajo
esta curva es igual a 1 sin importar
cuál sea el valor de está ahora si yo
tomara valores cada vez más pequeños de
tau que es lo que va a pasar
supongamos que mi nueva está o va a ser
igual
al punto de acá va a estar aquí mi nueva
está o en otro color entonces mi valor
de 1 entre dos estados va a estar más
alto como es un humano más pequeño está
o mi denominador va a ser más pequeño
numerador un poquito más grande en
comparación por lo que la altura de esto
va a ser mayor y si voy reduciendo cada
vez más mis valores aceptado pues la
altura en mi valor en nfc va a ser cada
vez más más y más alta y creo que ya se
están dando cuenta hacia dónde quiero
llegar qué pasa cuando el límite de mi
valor de estado
se aproxima a cero
el límite cuando todo se aproxima a cero
de mi función de ese subíndice estado de
t cuál va a ser el límite de esto con
forma de estas cosas se vayan haciendo
infinitamente más pequeñas pues mi
altura va a estar tendiendo cada vez más
hacia el infinito pero no importa cuál
sea mi valor de tao el área bajo esta
curva siempre siempre va a ser igual a 1
así que terminaremos con nuestra función
delta de dirac permíteme escribirlas
bonito dirac delta de t y debido a esto
si nosotros preguntamos bueno cuál es el
límite cuál será el límite cuando todo
tiende a cero de la integral de manos
infinito a infinito de subíndice estado
de t de t
esta va a seguir siendo uno esto se
sigue evaluando como uno no importa cuál
sea el valor que tome estado y aquí
estoy siendo bastante generosa con mis
definiciones de límites de menos
infinito al infinito esto va a ser igual
a 1 y con este mismo argumento podemos
decir que el límite de menos infinito a
infinito
de nuestra función delta dídac de t de t
va a ser igual también a 1 y de la misma
manera nuestra función delta de dirac
esto va a ir hasta el infinito cuando te
es igual a cero si yo aquí de nuevo
dibujará mi eje x bueno mi eje de las
tres y pusiera aquí de igual a cero mi
función del debilidad sería esta seria
hacia arriba aquí en este punto y de
hecho vamos a poner una flecha kim
indicando que esta nuestra función delta
dídac de t
y qué pasa si queremos desplazar esto
qué pasa si queremos desplazarlo bueno
ahora voy a representar mi función delta
de irak como t menos 3 digamos que vamos
a mover las tres lugares hacia la
derecha cuando te sea igual a 3 esta va
a ser la función delta de jacques de 0
como representaría esto gráficamente
bueno digamos que emite va a ser igual a
3 y aquí estoy dibujando mi eje de las
'tres simplemente vamos a estar
desplazando hacia la derecha tres
unidades cuando te sea igual a tres se
va a volver nuestra función delta de
dirac de cero así que esta gráfica voy a
poner aquí estos valores 1 2 3 en mi
gente y en mi eje y voy a tener un valor
aquí 1
y permíteme desdibujar aquí estos puntos
ya que te es igual a 3 la función delta
de vida que va a ser igual a 0 en
cualquier otro valor
excepto cuando t es igual a tres cuando
este es valor sea igual a tres nuestra
función de navidad va a ser
infinitamente alta y obviamente no tengo
espacio aquí para representar
adecuadamente este valor infinito sin
embargo aquí voy a divulgar esta fecha
tan verde esta fecha significa la
magnitud del área bajo la curva y
recordamos que por definición el área
bajo la curva de mi función delta dídac
es igual a 1 por eso es que esta flecha
llegas al valor de 1 ya que aunque sea
infinitamente a esta va a tener una base
infinitamente pequeña por lo que el área
se mantiene igual a 1 por lo que el área
bajo esta función impulso o esta función
de alta de irak va a ser igual a 1 por
eso es que hice que estas flechas
llegara hasta 1 digamos que ahorita
quisiera gráficas y bueno vamos a
hacerlo en diferente color
digamos que quiero graficar 2 x la
función delta de irak
dt menos 2
graficar y ah bueno sería 0 hasta que
llegara hasta igualados y aquí la
multiplicaría por el valor del tedh irak
dt menos 2 que es que es 0 y como estoy
multiplicando la por 2 va a ser esta
fecha con el valor igual a 2 y bueno
sabemos que ambas tienen al infinito
pero esta es al doble de la anterior
aunque bueno esto podría sonar algo
ridículo que esto sea el doble de
infinito que este otro pero la idea aquí
es que la de abajo esta curva debería
ser el doble del área bajo esta otra
curva y es por eso que hacemos esta
flecha el doble de alta que el anterior
esta es una manera muy útil de modelar
cosas que se comportan de la siguiente
manera donde de repente no pasa nada y
el momento suben tienen un pico y luego
volver al valor normal y aunque no lo
crean hay muchos fenómenos sobre todo en
la física él no necesita este tipo de
comportamiento y ahora cuando ustedes se
encuentra en ese tipo de funciones
podrán decir ay esa es una función delta
de irak
de modelar su impulso como sigue a
continuación y solo para darles un
poquito más de motivación en esto voy a
dibujar aquí un ejemplo un poquito más
de la vida real ya que les estado
diciendo muchas cosas teóricas
hemos visto ecuaciones diferenciales
pero no se les ha visto una aplicación
en la vida real aquí tenemos un muro que
está conectado a un resorte y al final
del resorte hay una masa una masa como
esta y digamos que este es el estado
natural del resorte por lo que ha sido
estirado una distancia ya del punto en
el que está en estado natural y digamos
que tenemos una fuerza externa que es la
que está estirando el resorte y aquí
tenemos hielo sobre hielo por lo que no
hay ningún tipo de fricción y aunque no
lo crean
yo puedo representar este tipo de
comportamiento con una ecuación
diferencial usando la función escalón
unitario y la función delta de irak en
donde que ya les podemos ver la utilidad
en este tipo de ambiente así que sabemos
qué
o la fuerza va a ser igual a la masa por
la aceleración que es una fórmula física
de las más básicas cuáles serán las
fuerzas que están involucradas en este
sistema o actuando sobre esta masa
tenemos esta fuerza de aquí que va en la
dirección positiva hacia la derecha está
esta fuerza
y también tenemos la fuerza del resorte
que es en sentido contrario a la fuerza
del resorte de acuerdo con la ley de
hook es proporcional a qué tan lejos ha
sido estirado de su estado natural así
que la fuerza en esta dirección va a ser
negativa va a ser menos acá porque las
fuerzas que actúan sobre nuestra masa
son efe - k porque es igual a la masa de
nuestro objeto multiplicado por la
aceleración y con esa aceleración si la
posición es y si tomamos la derivada de
y con respecto a mi prima va a ser igual
a velocidad y si tomamos la segunda
derivada de o derivamos la velocidad y
el doble prima va a ser igual a la
aceleración así que ponemos que esto de
prima de doble prima es igual a la
aceleración así que escribimos aquí que
la fuerza menos cada porque es igual a
la masa por doble prima entonces ya lo
podemos sustituir en nuestra fórmula así
que logran escribir a pues escribimos ya
doble prima
y si ponemos esto del otro lado de la
ecuación que es lo que vamos a obtener
pues vamos a tener que nuestra fuerza
esta otra fuerza va a ser igual a
nuestra masa por la aceleración más la
constante del resorte por ye yé es
nuestra posición así que si no
tuviéramos ninguna fuerza externa
esto sería cero y tendríamos una
ecuación diferencial homogénea pero ésta
efe hace que tengamos un término no
homogéneo es la fuerza externa que
estamos aplicando a este sistema a esta
masa así que esta fuerza externa es una
función del tipo delta de irak
dt menos 2 que es igual a m por la doble
derivada de ella más k que es nuestra
constante del resorte porque que es
nuestra posición esto es lo mismo que
decir que cuando t es igual a 2 vamos a
tener que va a haber un jalón aquí hacia
la derecha vamos a tener un impulso de 2
su fuerza por el tiempo va a ser le
recordamos que el impulso es 1 entonces
y no me quiero meter demasiado en la
física aquí el impulso va a cambiar su
momento y tendrá una magnitud de 1
dependiendo de cuáles sean nuestras
unidades pero bueno de todas maneras lo
que yo quería hacer aquí es mostrarles
un ejemplo de la vida cotidiana y donde
se pueden aplicar todas estas cosas
extrañas que les he estado explicando en
los últimos vídeos ya que existen
ocasiones en las que ustedes pueden
sacudir esto en alguna magnitud y aquí
están simulando algo que podría ser
infinitamente rápido pero lo suficiente
para cambiar el momento de esto en una
forma bien definida pero bueno ahora que
conocemos la función delta de dídac
podemos encontrar su transformada de la
clase
y ver cómo está puede afectar otras
transformadas